snowy woods broad plateaus the highlands
of the Black Forest are full of
well-prepared ski trails cross-country
skiers can spend days on them in peace
and quiet surrounded by the beauty of
nature but learning to glide elegantly
takes practice and maybe even some
lessons before starting out participants
in Kirsten go Springs cross-country
course practice falling down running to
fall is essential because you also go
downhill in cross-country and if you
don't know how to fall you can hurt
yourself
older people often have hip problems
fallings easier if you're younger but
you have to get up again today all the
participants are beginners like Sarah
Hagar she's been downhill skiing for
ages but now she's trying on
cross-country skis for the first time
she also has to learn how to use the
longer poles it's pretty different
because I usually alpine ski the
bindings are on - the way your heel
comes up at the back it's a bit wobbly
and they're off using what's called the
herringbone technique pointing the tips
of their skis outwards it's one way to
climb a steep hill and it certainly
exercises your thigh muscles the snow is
wet so it's heavier than powder for the
inexperienced skiers it's quite a
workout
Bethan even acting it's best not to
think about it
just take the poles along with you and
we'll ski for a bit and if it works out
well you can even try to kick a bit to
the back using the balls of your feet
on the panorama trail near Toth now on
Mont Feldberg it's less steep
now all the participants can find their
rhythm and they're making better
progress there are more than 170
cross-country trails at all levels of
difficulty in the Black Forest Highlands
they connect to form one of the largest
networks of trails in Europe with a
total length of 1,200 kilometres
this was a nice here what's special here
is that there are relatively flat trails
but it still poses a challenge even for
really good skiers you can choose
between level areas like in dirt Sartain
where you're really just strolling along
and the toward now trail which is
strenuous because it's so steep so
there's something for everyone and of
course the scenery is gorgeous we're not
in the high peaks of the Alps here it's
more rounded hills but you still have an
Alpine view you feel free up here and
that's what's special about the Black
Forest now the group is learning without
poles it's important to move the way you
did before but now without poles we can
practice now while standing take up a
position here and move your arms
diagonally right forwards left forwards
right left
really energetically and it's important
to bend and stretch your knees the
instructor makes the exercise look easy
in just two hours they've learned all
the basics of cross-country skiing at
first I was a bit unsteady but kerosine
demonstrated it again she's skied in
front of me and that really helped and
like a good coach she encourages them to
the end